hi everyone I'm Lin Clark and I make
Coke cartoons and I also work at Mozilla
of course we make the Firefox browser
but you might not know we have a few
other browser projects in the works at
the moment too and one of them uses
react so I was working on this project I
was hacking on it I thought I should
really dive more deeply into Reax
internals to see how it's doing things
so that I can make our project more
performant and what happened when I do
that is I had to step through the
virtual Dom algorithm over and over and
over and over and over and over again
and so I figured as long as I had gone
through that process I might as well
write it down and turn it into a cartoon
so that other people could share the
benefit of that so that is what started
this talk I'm gonna be focusing on the
performance what you can do to make your
react apps more performant and I should
start by saying that I'm not gonna be
telling you anything that you don't
already know I'm gonna be talking about
things like keys and should component
update and immutability the reason I
wanted to talk about them though is
because I think that we often have this
fuzzy concept of the ideas around
performance again we don't really take
the time to bring those concepts into
focus so this means that the knowledge
about these ideas
it's just received knowledge you know
you just add a show component update
because somebody told you on was
standing on a stage and they told you to
do that but not all recommendations work
the same in all situations so I want to
bring these concepts around performance
into focus so that you can have a better
understanding of the why behind each
recommendation and I should also say
before I start that I'm focusing on a
very specific part of render perform of
performance and react and that is
performance during the render cycle so
other things that you can do to make
react more performant are things like if
you're in production use the production
version of react those kinds of things
does have a huge impact and a lot of
people slip up and don't realize that
they're doing that but
I'm not gonna talk about those little
gotchas so the talks gonna go a little
something like this
first I'm gonna talk about the basics of
rendering in the browser so how the
browser actually renders your web page
and what parts of that can possibly be
slow and then I'm gonna talk about what
react does to minimize and batch Dom
changes with the virtual Dom to make it
a little bit faster and then I'm gonna
cover what you can do to make react even
faster than that so let's start with
number one how the browser builds your
web page how it actually renders the
page and what parts are slow and you can
kind of think of this in the same way
that you think of developing the website
yourself so there's work that takes
place over time and there's an initial
period of work this would be before the
initial launch if you were developing
you know in the development process and
in react this is the initial render and
then there are updates that happen after
that so in if you were working on a
project that would be any feature
updates if you're working in react that
is gonna be something like this that
says date updating the UI to extend this
metaphor your code is kind of like the
project Li planning the project and
telling folks what to do unfortunately
your code only has one person working on
this project for it and that's the main
thread so the main thread is kind of
like a JavaScript developer it err sorry
it's kind of like a full-stack developer
it covers JavaScript the Dom and layout
just as when you're working on a project
in real life if you only have one person
working on the project you're gonna
limit the number of tasks that you
assign to that one person if you want
that project to be delivered on time but
before we know how to reduce the amount
of work that the main thread is doing we
need to know more about the work that
the main thread does so as I mentioned
before the main thread is in charge of
JavaScript so this is you know you're
familiar with JavaScript this is where
you define your functions where you call
functions
the DOM is the way the functions tell
the page what to do
basically the Dom gives you a set of
objects that you can move around and
manipulate in order to change what the
browsers rendering and the way that this
works is that there's something behind
the scenes called the render tree and so
the main thread combines the Dom with
CSS to create the render tree and it
figures out a thing from that called the
box model and this is what it passes off
to the thing that actually passes the
pixels to the page this little process
is called a reflow and that computation
takes a bit of time so the main thread
doesn't do it on every single Dom change
instead what it tries to do is bash
those changes together so that it can
cover more of them in a single pass
through computing the render tree so the
way this works is you know your code
might say change the class name on that
button and then the main thread goes
over and does it and then additive the
main thread goes over and does it and
then add another button the main thread
goes over and does it the main thread
will also meet a note to itself sometime
in the future I need to recalculate that
render tree and so when that time in the
future comes is going to go over to the
render tree and calculate all of those
things together so we want to reduce the
amount of work that the main thread is
doing here you might have figured out
two good ways one way is to reduce the
number of Dom changes and another way is
to batch those Dom changes together in
time so that the main thread can take
care of all that recalculation on the
same reflow and this is something that
react helps you do now I want to be
clear react isn't the only way to do
this it's actually not even a necessary
way of doing this these ideas have been
around since well before react so it's
not that react is necessarily more
performant than vanilla JavaScript the
thing is in order to get these
performance gains your code has to be
smart your code needs to know how to
direct the main thread pretty precisely
to do these things
so go back to the metaphor your code
needs to be able it's a really really
good product manager it needs to know
what to display in this webpage and it
also needs to be a really really good
tech lead it needs to know how to build
the page in the most efficient way of
course your code is only as smart as you
make it so that means that all of the
developers on your team have to have a
really solid understanding of how these
things work together and they need to
not be prone to making mistakes they
always need to be on their game on top
of their game
so what react does for you is it
offloads that work it's kind of like
your code brings in the consultant to do
all the tech leave work and that frees
up your code just to be a good product
manager so that your code can just focus
on what needs to be displayed not on how
to make it happen so let's take a look
at how these to react in your code work
together to direct the main thread in
shipping and I won't be showing the main
thread through the rest of the slides
but just assume wherever you're seeing
work being done the main thread is there
so this brings us to part two how react
minimizes work using the virtual DOM and
I'm going to start this off with a UI
that we're gonna build so this UI is
just a list of numbers and when you
click the button the numbers multiply by
itself so let's walk through the initial
render on this most are from the very
beginning a user is downloaded some HTML
and it's been parsed and there is an
HTML element that's going to serve as
the container for the react app and your
code has been loaded and react has been
loaded along with your code these things
called components have been loaded and
so these are kind of like deputy product
managers that know about specific parts
of the page and what they should render
and in case you aren't familiar this is
what code that corresponds to react Dom
render and then the first parameter is
list asking as a react element and then
the second parameter is the HTML
container that we were just talking
about so we covered that HTML container
but what is the react element
it's a way for your code to handoff
requirements to react to tell react what
needs to be displayed so following the
analogy it's like a little note card
that has a few notes about what react
needs to build it has the type which is
the component that's gonna be used to
build the thing and has the props and
children and reacts gonna hold on to the
style element is just gonna tuck this
note card away until it's ready to build
the thing the thing that it builds using
these specs using this these
requirements is an instance of the
component so an instance is the thing
that holds on to the state is the thing
that you call this dot set state on the
thing that holds on to the Refs
it's the thing that react uses to figure
out whether or not it means to update
the Dom but you don't actually interact
with instances too much you don't need
to manage instances react manages the
instances for you you just need to give
it these requirements and form of
elements so your code asks for an
element and react creates it and then
your code tells react to start rendering
this is react Dom render your code tells
react to start rendering that element
into the container and this begins
construction of reacts render tree now
if you don't follow I'm gonna have to
move through this pretty quickly but
this is being recorded so you can catch
up on it there and if you want a version
of this for yourself I've posted it on
Twitter both Lin Clark & Co cartoons so
you can go there and download a version
of this I should say say before I start
going through this algorithm it has
changed it actually has changed since I
started writing this talk and it will
change again there are some pretty big
changes to this algorithm in the
pipeline currently but for now this is
how it works so react starts by creating
this thing called a top level wrapper
and it's just a little implementation
detail it makes it easier for react to
wrap up some stuff together then it
creates an instance of that top level
wrapper and it sets it so that when it
calls render on that top level wrapper
is going to render to the list this is
the raft element that was passed in
which has now been instantiated
so it's that's the province date on the
list and then it wants to create the
corresponding Dom for the list but
unfortunately it doesn't know how you
know if this were a div react knows
about divs and knows what Dom it needs
to create for a div react element it
needs to create a div HTML element but
since this is something that it doesn't
know about it's gonna have to ask so it
asks the component and list responds
okay well I'm gonna need you to create
some elements for me I need you to
create a button element and I need you
to create for each thing that's in my
this dot state items list I need you to
create an item element and then I need
you to create a div to wrap all of those
so reactive takes all those elements
builds them out and then tucks them away
and the only one that it cares about
right now is that wrapping div so it'll
pull that out of the pile and create the
instance for that and because this is a
div it knows what the AMA needs to
create for the div so it goes over to
the Dom and creates that no note it
didn't actually make that div a child of
the container that's there that would
have scheduled that reflow instead what
it wants to do is wait until all of the
nodes are there before it schedules that
reflow so now to do that to get all
those dominoes there is gonna need to
create instances of all of the children
and for this that goes from a complex to
a simple structure it goes from this
nested array into an object and that
object has property names that
correspond to the structure of that
array so the first item is dot 0 the the
name of the first item is dot 0 and
that's because the button was the 0th
item in that array now the items they
have more complex names because they're
in a nested structure so dot one dot 0
is the first item dot one dot one is the
second item so react takes this
flattened list increased the instances
from that now it's time to make the Dom
elements
so react knows how to create the Dom for
a button and it goes over and does that
then it gets the items and once again
these are things that it doesn't know
how to create the Dom for so it has to
ask again and so the item is going to
say okay I need you to create a div
element and take the prop that was
passed in to me and turn that into text
content so we got crease the element and
then the instance and then the Dom node
it does this two more times to get that
full set of Dom nodes then it goes over
to the Dom and it wires up all of those
children to their parent and then hooks
up the wrapper div to the container div
and this is what's gonna trigger that
reflow but you notice that it waited to
the end to trigger that that's that
batching that I was talking about before
that way the main thread can handle
these changes all at once so we get our
riu I and it's ready for people to
interact with it let's see how the how
the virtual Dom actually handles that
user interaction so the users going to
click the button and react figures out
the onclick handler for the click and it
does this using something called event
delegation unfortunately I don't have
time to go into what event delegation is
but you can find an explanation of it
and the react Doc's so from there calls
the handler and the handler would be
code like this you know you get a list
of items from the state perform
operations on the items then call set
state with the items and if he thinks
that you see a possible bug with this
code we're gonna get to that later
so the handler would have been defined
in the list component it would have been
bound to the list instance when it calls
this thought set state it calls set
state on that list instance so what
happens when set state is called what
react does is it sets up a few different
lists it takes the partial state that
was passed in with this dot set state
and it adds it to an array on the
instance of pending state changes and
then it takes that instance and it adds
it to this thing called the dirty
components array and these are all of
the things that are going to need to be
updated but it doesn't take care of
those yet it waits to see if that
clickhandler might have done any other
things might have set ste on any other
instances before it actually starts
processing this once it's figured out if
there have or haven't been any other
updates it goes through and it flushes
this cue and since this is the only
thing on this cue this is the only thing
that we're going to process so we start
with the instance that had sets they
called and work down from there I'm just
praying everything out react hold on to
all of these things so it can do
comparisons between the previous and the
next but this will make it easier for
you to see what's going on so react
calculates the next state on the
instance and sets that and then it has
to ask the component okay now that you
have this new state what are you gonna
rend you to now and so the component
responds and it creates the new elements
the new set of elements that it would
render to and from there it updates the
instances and then it compares the
instances the previous instances to the
new ones and figures out whether or not
easy to make Dom changes so for the
button it doesn't need to make any Dom
changes because the button hasn't
changed at all that gets to the first
item and it's gonna have to ask the item
again what do you render to before it
figures out whether or not item is has
changed or not so item responds that
creates the element for that updates the
div instance and since there were no
changes you know in the previous list it
was one in the new list is one that text
content hasn't changed it figures it can
save a little work by not going over to
them not making any changes to the Dom
for that so then for the second one it
has to go through that same process it
updates the instance and figures out
actually there is a change between these
two so
goes over to the domina makes the change
and then it does the same thing for the
third one and that's when you get that
reflow because those two happened in
pretty quick succession they probably
hit the same reflow so this is how react
makes things faster figures up the
smallest number of changes that it needs
to make to the Dom and it batches them
all together so that the browser can do
a smaller number of reflows but there's
still a good amount of work happening
here so how could we reduce this and
this brings us to the third part of the
talk which is what you can do to make
react faster and the first technique is
one that you probably already know
because react yells at you if you don't
do it whenever you're creating an array
of children it's going to tell you that
you should be using keys for those
children so I want to show you why this
can help your performance to do this I'm
going to need to switch up my example
we're going to be we're gonna have a
list of fruits in alphabetical order and
when you click the button they're gonna
reverse order so we've gotten part of
the way through the set state process
this is where it starts to get
interesting this is where react is
actually dealing with the children those
items that have changed order so if you
remember when it was flattening them it
was turning that nested array into a
flat object and assigning these property
names and from that it updated the
instance of instances of the children
and then compared the old instances to
the new instances let's look more
closely at how that comparison happens
so reacts looking at the old set and the
new set and it's going to look at the
two things that have the same name so
dot one zero and one zero and each of
these lists so the name is just the
index of the array and we reversed the
order this means that react is comparing
apples to oranges quite literally in
this case Apple was at position zero
before and now oranges so when it
compares these two lists
it thinks it needs to update the values
of all of the items that are in the list
except for the middle one because they
all look different than they used to now
let's say that we had given react
meaningful keys something like the
actual name of the fruit the key would
then be used in that name and then react
can tell which of the previous instances
corresponds to which of the next
instances and you can tell that nothing
but change changed about the order so we
know that I can just reorder those Dom
nodes now in this case it's not a huge
difference but just imagine if each of
these were a complex Dom structure that
could be a real time savings only moving
them around instead of recreating them
but it's only really a time savings if
your list is gonna be reordered like if
you're going to reverse the order or
take something out of the middle of the
array if you aren't changing the order
then there's no real performance impact
to this and that's one of the reasons
why it's important to understand the why
behind any recommendation because
recommendations don't always have the
same impact across different use cases
so let's look at a use case where this
adding keys wouldn't have as much of a
performance impact but we're another
trick would so it's a list where items
are being fetched from a server and
added to the end of a list and let's say
the user pushes the button but there are
no new messages
so racks gonna go through the entire
process of building out this render tree
of building out the elements and the
instances and everything but it's not
going to change anything in the Dom so
this is called wasted time you can see
it react perf tools and how can we avoid
wasting time like this
I'm sure you've heard of one way and
that's should component update what
happens is when the user clicks and this
dots that state is called before
building up the render tree below the
list react will ask the component a
question it'll say if I give you these
next props and next state do you need an
update
and then the list will say no I'm good
so react won't call render or do
anything else on that component or
children so this is great because we can
skip computing the list and everything
under it we can save a whole lot of
processing there but if you were looking
closely at that should component update
you might have noticed a potential bug
and this works hand-in-hand with the
potential bug I was calling out in the
handler before it depends on how you're
updating the state so let's say you that
you were updating it the way that I was
saying where you set a new variable next
items to this dot state items and then
you push an item on the array and then
call set state with that next items
variable what would happen here is that
you'd never see the new items rendered
in your UI your should component update
would always return false why is that
it's because even though you have two
names for this thing they're both
pointing at the same object the exact
same thing and when you do an equals
check in JavaScript on object variables
it just checks that the two variables
point to the same object so even if you
make a change the should component
update is going to think that the old
state and the new state are the same so
it's not gonna see this change now you
could make it so that whenever you do
call that handler whenever you are
calling this offset state what you're
doing is creating a new object from the
old one using something like object
assign then your she'd component update
would see that the previous and the new
one are different the problem is it
would think that they're worth always
something that was different between
them because it was always pointing to a
new object so it would never return
false your should component update would
be completely ineffective now you could
do a deep equality check where you
compare the actual values but depending
on how heavy that is it might actually
take more time so be nice to have that
simple quick qualities check
but still catch changes in the data and
this is what immutability gives you so
with immutable data if two variables are
pointing to the same object you know
that the data hasn't changed and if it
does need to change you create a new
object so if you're using immutable data
then you can do these quick Equality
checks which are fast and should
component update so with should
component update you can short-circuit
work lower in the tree than the place
where you call this not that state but
what if the change happens in one of the
children do you still need to compute
this whole set of things let's walk
through that case so we have a to do
list and we check off one of the items
that item has to change but the rest of
the list the other items in the list and
Alyssa itself they don't really need to
change so how can you make sure that you
aren't updating those other things when
you're using vanilla react with local
component State it's actually pretty
easy you just restructure your state so
that you can call set state lowering the
tree but when you're using something
like Redux this can be harder to do
that's because you're firing off actions
and then the state is coming in through
connect and most people will use connect
at the top level of their tree or many
people well there is a way to do this
though and that's the using connect at
lower levels of the tree now if you're
gonna do this you'll probably need to
rethink how you're handling your data
for this to work because you'd have a
component structure like this and most
people would pass in their array of
items to the list and then those would
be passed down to each item component so
when an item needs to be changed it not
only needs to change in the item itself
but also in the array that's being
passed to list so that's trigging
triggering an update at the list level
but you can reduce the work here and the
way you do that is by passing in IDs to
the list and then passing those ids down
to the
items and from there you can actually
use the ID and map map state two props
to convert that ID into the item and so
then when the item is changed you only
see that change in the item itself so
this is how you can save them work at
higher levels and sibling levels of the
tree I wish I've had time to cover other
performance tricks things like
memoization and virtualization and
incremental rendering and how you could
use observables which things like mob X
and relay used to notify components of
changes but this is gonna have to be it
for now so here are the techniques that
we covered using keys to help react
match previous instances to me once
using should component updates a short
circuit to work lower in the tree and
how immutability factors into that and
using set seed or connect lower in the
tree so you can reduce work higher in
the tree so I hope this has given you a
good overview of a few starting points
as you can see there are lots of tweaks
that you can make some of them are a for
some cases some of them are a for other
cases and some actually had negative
impacts if they're used in the wrong way
in the wrong circumstances so this is
why people say it's good to measure and
hopefully this talk is giving you a good
framework for understanding what it is
that you're measuring thank you